[Musique]
les mecs tu préfères avoir 30 millions
d'euros ou alors 30 millions d'amis
fidèles sans hésiter 30 millions d'amis
fidèles ah ouais pourquoi si je demande
à chacun le soin de me donner 5 euros et
que ce sont vraiment des amis fidèles et
le flon et donc j'aurai 150 millions
d'euros oh et si je veux présenter en
tant que président bob j'aurai 30
millions devant sa web bien vu chacal
alors si je décide d'ouvrir un business
comme un café par exemple j'aurais déjà
30 millions de clients tu vas vous
pensez à faire sont pauvres si je vends
un café à un euro et que je demande à
chacun de mes vrais amis de m'acheter à
café à un euro chaque jour et bien cela
me fait 30 millions d'euros par jour
oui l'amour est-ce que c'est très
possible que j'ai par exemple une bière
un mois ça sera avec plaisir mais le bar
est fermé mais moi n'importe quoi ce que
tu veux un truc n'importe quoi tous ces
plaisirs à moi je peux te donner la
partie sortira un qu'est ce que tu en
penses oui mais je vais prendre la porte
un nom un brin
[Musique]
là
son nom au
zimbabwe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]